along Florida's Gulf Coast thousands of
people filed into a hockey arena near
Fort Myers yesterday seeking shelter at
least 11 shelters in Lee County are now
at capacity Kris Van Cleave is in Fort
Myers where people are trying to escape
what could be historic storm surge Chris
good morning good morning Gail already
we're seeing water start to collect on
the ground that shelter you were talking
about the germain arena is full let me
show you what the roads look like for
the most part they are empty and that's
exactly what police want
we're mainly just seeing police driving
around because you know the wind isn't
too bad right now but it's gonna get a
whole lot worse here's what the police
are telling us we didn't know whether
this was going east coast or west coast
but the one thing that we have said all
week long this storm is bigger than the
state of Florida it spreads over 400
miles so we wanted to make sure we drove
that point home we're taking it
seriously we want everyone else to take
it seriously and at this point again
that this is the the final minute we
want everybody to stay put stay
sheltered stay safe the final minute
time is running out if in fact there's
only three last resort shelters still
open here in the Fort Myers area more
than 27,000 people have gone to those
evacuation centers Nora well Chris thank
you it's good that people are heeding
the call and going to those shelters
where hopefully they will be safe before
this filling up - that's right